i'm totally convinced that the end of my
football career is just the beginning of
something i haven't even discovered yet
life is not shrinking for me
it's morphing into a whole new world of
possibilities
that was peyton manning more than three
years ago as he embarked on his
post-playing career lots of chapters
still to be written for peyton manning
who's still in his early 40s but we
decided to parlay the rumor of the jets
wanting peyton manning to come run their
football operations into a draft for
this monday edition of pro football talk
live the most memorable post playing
careers with two caveats chris one
no announcers
two no coaches so with those removed
because they would be all announcers and
coaches if we did that so we're gonna do
the most memorable post playing career
and the key word is memorable could be
good could be bad could be neutral but
memorable is the key so go ahead it's
it's the forgettable rigged coin toss
where chris calls tails he knows tails
is always where it comes up on monday go
ahead no it's going heads here heads all
the way go heads it's not a rig coin
toss i'm just that good see i'm that
good
i am so in kristen's head in the back
she's trying to make you win mike just
so you know but i am that amazing of
being the oracle of heads and tails the
oracle of heads
if you were that good at reading defense
you should still be playing in the nfl
exactly right i wouldn't be here with
you that's for sure i know that okay my
first pick uh i'm going with roger
stallback most memorable post-playing
career yeah it might not be like that
memorable as far as national headlines
or things like that but roger stallback
after his awesome career as you know
being captain comeback and mr clutch and
all the great things he did he opens
opened up a real estate firm and i've
always knew about this but i was even in
amazement as i was looking it up last
night a little bit i just didn't realize
he capitalized in the way he did uh but
uh i had his own real estate agency of
course it became very successful and
they sold it about 10 years ago for 613
million dollars pretty good day's work
right there uh but i look at that as
going uh that's an unbelievable
successful very memorable post-playing
career i don't know it might not be that
memorable as far as national headlines
but man i i would i would remember all
that money going in my bank account
sorry
welcome back to the mike francesca show
uh no um
uh
what are you doing what are you doing
there's been plenty of great businessmen
how do how can why not memorable tell me
tell me all of it all the funny ones
he's killing it 613 million keep going
ahead let me hear another one
money plenty let me tell you something
how can it be memorable if we're not
even aware of it it has to be something
that we know about i've never thought
twice about roger staubach post-playing
other than seeing him somewhere and
saying hey there's roger staubach i
didn't even know what he did after he
quit playing you needed you need to
follow the football a little bit more i
knew he was doing i followed him
oh i follow the football all right uh
look this is one and this is why i
emphasize memorable because i i i don't
approve oh here he should be
nancy on a monday morning go ahead oj
simpson how is that not the most
memorable post football playing career
the guy had the trial of the century
dominated everyone's conscience to the
point where people even forgot he played
football and he was a hall of famer o.j
simpson without question i mean i think
the guy's guilty i think he should be in
jail and he's lived this notorious life
afterward he went back to jail uh with
the uh the the the what he tried to do
he tried to
steal his own memorabilia that people
had taken from him and they were selling
and he was trying to whatever it was but
he went to jail and he just got out a
year ago o.j simpson without question
again notorious not not a respectable
post uh playing career but uh yeah by
far that's the obvious no-brainer first
pick i i guess it's not really within
the spirit of the what we're talking
about we're talking about manning
getting a job and having something
successful happen so yeah i have no
emphasized growth i'm glad you
emphasized that four seconds before we
started the segment that was great that
you emphasized it then we had a text
message going on
last night okay i have the receipts you
went to bed at eight that's your problem
memorable it's memorable okay great i
that that was a horrible pick that's
stupid he had no success actually thank
you oh my stayed awake during mine it's
going to michael strahan okay as far as
memorable i mean come on michael strahan
hall of fame
nfl defense end and goes into the
entertainment business and becomes a a
superstar i mean good morning america uh
or whatever the heck the show is he's on
in the morning good morning america he
was on region that's the way to make
your case you're making one hell of a
case he was on regis and kelly there for
a while of course where it was michael
strahan and kelly i mean come on that's
a
let alone also being on fox you know
sunday pre-game show uh i just i look at
michael strahan and just go gosh he's a
hall of fame football player and he's
already having a hall of fame career
after the fact and it's not just about
talking about football it's about you
know every genre underneath the sun and
uh he's pretty much killed it to me so
yes i am going with michael strahan as
my second pick
that's a fine line i almost threw the
challenge flag on you because he got
started as an announcer he's on the fox
pregame show and he's still on it now
yeah but i i'll i'll let you slide on
he's not announcing the pregame show
that's not enough
well but but it still counts it's
yeah you're not you're not going to be
included in this you're in the bucket as
well um but uh the the idea that he he
wanted very much wanted to replace regis
philbin and got it and then parlayed
that into good morning america he
basically did what tiki barber wanted to
do tiki barber couldn't michael strahan
did and god only knows how much money
he's making now with everything that
he's doing so i'll give you that one far
more memorable than roger staubach by
the way no disrespect intended to roger
staubach all right for me look i'm going
to
look because we only excluded coaching
we didn't exclude executives and i've
said this many a time if ozzie newsom
didn't already have a bust in the hall
of fame for his time as a tight end with
the browns he would deserve a bust in
the hall of fame for what he did as the
longtime general manager of the
baltimore ravens unparalleled success
the draft in 1996 amid all that turmoil
as the browns moved to baltimore and
everything that was going on they still
were able to focus in and get jonathan
ogden and ray lewis in the same round of
the same draft two hall of famers in one
draft in the year that they moved
unbelievable what ozzie newsome did i
think single-handedly the person most
responsible for the two super bowls the
franchise has won and and if they did
have
a way that a guy could go into i mean a
second could put a second bus put a
young ozzie newsome bust in there and an
older ozzie newsome bust because he
should get a separate bust for what he's
done as the general manager of the
baltimore rave i wouldn't disagree with
you there i mean he it was pretty
awesome i mean what ozzie newsom built
in baltimore was special uh you know eye
for a talent eye for the proper attitude
that fit within the organization's theme
tough physical uh just phenomenal way
about him and of course baltimore was
relevant and in the payoff conversation
almost every year of the aussie newsom
era so certainly one of the better gm's
in football uh in in in football history
so i get you there that's a good one all
the way i'm going along the same lines
for my third round pick i'm going with
john elway i mean hey john elway you
could talk about yeah we won two super
bowls he played in five post playing
career i mean elways restaurant uh i
don't know if anybody's been out to
denver first of all elways is a huge uh
it's a two great restaurants that i know
of there in the city been a huge success
you better get a free meal the next time
you're out there no i don't get any free
meals but what he's done as i don't even
know what his official title is with the
denver broncos he's the man that's all i
know he is is he the president of
football operations or vice president i
believe he is but regardless he's
brought the denver broncos since he's
been running the show there in denver to
two super bowls okay they won one of
them uh i think it's a pretty stellar
career that he's had post-playing career
whether it's business ventures off the
field or what he's done with the denver
broncos as an executive
yeah look i i don't disagree with that i
think he is the president of football
operations and basically he's in charge
of everything that they do on that on
that uh side of the operation i wasn't
sure if joe ellis
was the president joe ellis joe ellis is
the is like this i don't know ceo cfo
ceo see something i don't know there's
too many there's too many initials out
there for me to understand what they all
are but you know i remember when i got
the job i was very skeptical because he
didn't have any experience he he's
walking like no one else was going to
hire him to be essentially the gm of a
football operation it was only the
broncos because of what he did as a
player this wasn't a guy who who worked
his way up and and went you know from
school to school grinding it out as a
scout and learning the trade from the
inside out i was very very skeptical and
i was the first one to admit i was wrong
once they were you're not skeptical
about peyton manning though with that
and that from that no no no because i
think i because i because i've learned
i've i've seen the light i mean i wasn't
skeptical about john lynch i was
skeptical about matt millen but uh i i
think the pain i just think that peyton
manning gets it and i think peyton
manning will will put in every moment
necessary to understand exactly what it
takes to be successful as the gm vp of
football operations whatever title you
give him with an nfl team all right
look i've already won this thing uh
nobody talks about o.j simpson in 10
years you didn't win anything all my
people are more relevant and better go
ahead all right
look and and we did not place any limit
on a guy's playing career and this guy
only spent two years in the nfl he
played for the raiders in 1970 and 1970
oh my god you're gonna lose the draft
here no i'm not gonna lose the draft
because you left apollo creed on the
board baby carl weathers you're talking
about this guy played in the doesn't
even count and he became a paul yes it
counts no he plays two-year careers guys
like that don't count guys okay he
became how long did you play he became
eight four times more than that four
times more eight are you apollo creed
you look kind of like uh what's the
other guy the russian guy but
drago uh i i'm just telling you one of
the most iconic movies of all times the
the best sports movie of all time hands
down a franchise that still spawns
movies and he was chubs in happy gilmore
that pushes him over the top you know
that was awesome without a doubt yeah i
mean that's just against the spirit of
the what we were talking about today
though there was better options out
there and people who have had more
two-year careers almost disqualification
people know more people know what what
carl weathers did after him
none of those people know he played now
so now they do i won this one it's not
even close you kind of bent the rules
and did whatever you wanted to do no oh
jason tried to have a memorable year and
that's about it it hasn't been a good
memory sorry buddy i i played to the
limit of the rules memorable former
player there was no limit on how long he
played and the question was
memorable so o.j simpson far and away
the most memorable career of any former
nfl player there are the picks staubach
strahan elway for sims o.j simpson ozzie
newsom karl weathers aka apollo creed
aka chubs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports